وقفه مع الحدث مع ازمير عبد الله العلي
اهلا ومرحبا بك همم معنا عبد الله همم
نتحدث اذا عن هذا الاعلان عن حل شرطه
الاخلاق
المتهمه في قضيه وفاه الشاب الايرانيه
مهسا اميني عبد الله لماذا ما زال الغموض
يعني يلف حقيقه الامر
لتعارض المؤثرات الملاحظه
اذا نظرنا من زاويه نجد ان ااه الاعداد
الموجوده في الشارع من افراد الشرطه ما
يسمى بشرطه الاخلاق اصبح قليلا وهنالك
اعداد متزايده من النساء اصبحنا على
الخروج في الشارع دون ارتداء الحجاب لكن
مع ذلك همم لابد من الملاحظه بان همم
الهيئه التي صدر عنها اعلانه حلي او تعليق
عملي همم شرطه الاخلاق هي هيئه غير مخوله
وهو مدعي العام والذي قال بان الهيئه او
الجهه التي كانت مسؤوله او التي انشات
شرطه الاخلاق اقامت بحلها والواقع ان
الهيئه التي انشات شرطه الاخلاق عام 2005
هي الحكومه الايرانيه وشرطه الاخلاق اذا
تابعه للحكومه الايرانيه والحكومه
الايرانيه لم يستر عنها حتى الان اي تاكيد
لخبر تعليق اعمال هذه الهيئه بل انه
يمكننا نذهب بعد ذلك نقول بان قناه العالم
التي تعتبر قناه ايرانيه ناطقه باللغه
العربيه وتابعه
لسلطات الايرانيه اشارت في مقال المنشور
على موقعها على الانترنت همم رفضت تاويلات
التي تقول بانه تم تعليقه عمل هذه الهيئه
شرطه الاخلاق او حلها وقالت بانه لم يصدر
عن اي اتجاهات الرسميه او عن اي جهه
حكوميه تاكيد لذلك القرار وبالتالي
فاضحي تماما ان هناك التذبذبا وهناك تخبطا
وهناك تناقضا ولبسا في هذه القضيه يعني هل
يعني الغاء هذا الجهاز انت تاكد طبعا
انتهاء الزاميه ارتداء الحجاب في ايران
اطلاقا لماذا اولا لان هذا القرار القرار
ارتداء الحجاب جاء بمفعول لقانون همم اقره
البرلمان الايراني عام
1984 وبالتالي ليس من حق الحكومه وليس من
حق السلطه التشريعيه القضاء ان ترغيه
وبالتالي اذا كانت السلطات الايرانيه
تجادده في مساله عدم منع همم نهائي
الزاميه ارتداء الحجاب فان عليها ان تصدر
قانونا يلغي ذلك القانون الاول وهو امر لم
يحصل حتى الان او همم قانون ان يبطل
مفاعيل وهذا لم يحصل وليس من الوارد على
ما يبدو حصوله ايضا على الاقل على الامد
القريب اللهم الا ان لم تحدث مفاجاه لاننا
نعرف بان المرشده العامه للثوره الايراني
الاعلال للثوره الايرانيه همم خميني يسر
ويتمسك بضروره الابقاء على الزاميه الحجاب
وهناك قرارات اتخذت في الاونه الاخيره تدل
ايضا دلاله واضحه على اصرار السلطات
الايرانيه على تطبيق ذلك للالتزام ليس على
النساء فقط ولكن على جهه اخرى فمثلا صدر
يحكى قرار بفصل مديري همم مؤسسه بنكيه
لانه استقبل سيده لا ترتدي الحجاب وبالامس
فقط يوم همم الاحد همم تم بدوه متابعه
قضائيه في حق مجموعه من التجار لانهن لان
اولئك التجار قبل ان يبيعوا بضائعه للنساء
قدمنا اليهم
وهن لا يرتدين الحجاب همم وهناك ايضا
ممثله ايرانيه اعلن بالامس انه تم
استدعائها الى احد اقسام الشرطه في طهران
لانها نشترت على حسابي على الانستغرام
صوره وهي لا ترتدي الحجاب اذا من الواضح
تماما انه ليس من الوارد على الاقل حتى
الان الغاءه الزاميه الحجاب بقرار او بنص
تشريعيه
البرلمان الايراني وليس من الوارد حسب
معلومتنا ايضا ان يقوم المرشد على الثوره
بمبادره في هذا الاتجاه وهناك والسلوطات
التنفيذيه لازال تسر على تنفيذ على فرض
احترامي همم ارتداء الحجاب ليس فقط على
النساء ولكن على بعض الجهات التي تستقبله
او تتعاطى مع نساء لا يرتدين الرجال
داخل دوائر القرار على الحراك هذا يدل
بالنسبه للكثيرين على ان هنالك تعددا في
مراكز القرار في ايران وهذا التعدد يمكن
للمحتاج ان ان يستغل
ويمكن اذا ما تاكد ايضا التراجع عن القرار
امر ليس واضحا الان اطلاقا كما اسرنا الى
ذلك ان يعتبر ضعفا اا اا ان يعتبر من قبل
المظاهرين متظاهرين ضعفا همم للنظام
الايراني وبالتالي من شان ذلك يحفز وان
يشجع المتظاهرين على المضي قدما في هذا
الحراك الذي بداهوه بداوه منذ منتصف في
سبتمبر ايه لولو للماضي همم بعد مقتل همم
الشابه مساء همم ميني همم بعد متابعتها
واعتقالها في احد اقسام الشرطه لانها لم
تكن تدير الحجاب بالنحو المناسب وفقا
لتعريف السلطات الايرانيه نحن نعرف بانه
هناك انس
زياده ملحوظه في عمليات القمع التي تقوم
بها السلطات الايرانيه وان هناك الاف
المعتقلين وانه هنالك عشره اشخاص على
الاقل تم الحكم عليهم بالاعدام في الاونه
الاخيره وان هنالك 450 تم قتلهم في اطار
عمليات القمع ضد المتظاهرين والبعض يقول
في ايران بان سب اختفاء شرطه الاخلاق من
الشارع العام او اا عدم ملاحظات اعداد
كبيره من افرادها هذه الشرطه هو ان
السلطات الايرانيه ارادت ان تكرر كل
قواتها وكل امكانياتها لقمع همم
المتظاهرين الذين يحتاجون في الشارع مما
ادى الى الصرف في هؤلاء العاملين في
الشرطه الاخلاق الى عمليات القمع بالنسبه
المتاهلين وليس فقط مراقبه ارتداء النساء
للحجاب ام لا شكرا والتوضيحات